[Music]
lady gaga has a plan to blow the roof
off the Super Bowl like nobody else
before thanks so much for joining us
everybody Kevin Frazier is in San
Francisco and it's quite the big day
there keV huh Nancy it's a great day
here in San Francisco I'm in town to
host the groundbreaking for the Golden
State Warriors brand new stadium and boy
are there lots of theatrics speaking of
theatrics a lot of people talking about
Lady Gaga's halftime show for the Super
Bowl because apparently it will be
second to none the challenge is to look
at it and say you know what can I do
differently how can i elevate certain
little things here and there and also
make it about the music
[Music]
is Gaga ready to risk her life for her
Super Bowl halftime show sure sounds
like it there's a new report out that
the pop star wants to perform on the
roof of Houston's energy Stadium a
member of the field team described her
plans this way
on a technical scale of one to ten it's
an 11 or 12 in a statement the NFL told
us quote people will have to wait and
see what we have in store we never
comment on speculation about the show
because there is so much misinformation
it surfaces yesterday the pop star
shared this image with our halftime team
writing we built a tent in my backyard
with a dance floor to practice more
halftime secrets today from ET online
senior music editor sophie shal AC an
NFL halftime source tells ET that Gaga
will have a special guest with her when
she performs no word on who that is
going to be yet but the source also
tells us that two big-name acts have
been asked and both said no and this is
interesting et has learned that there is
one topic that is off-limits for lady
gaga
and that's politics our source says that
the NFL told Gaga she is not allowed to
mention the election or Donald Trump
Gaga is already familiar with the Super
Bowl spectacle I really want to sing for
everyone
that was the best part about doing the
national anthem last year I was with
Gaga moments after that performance how
was it you tell me I don't know and as
amazing as Gaga can be we're wondering
if she can match Diana Ross's halftime
show from 1996 which ended with a
helicopter landing on the field and
flying her away there's still a lot for
Gaga to work out but we expect to learn
a lot more about the performance after
she holds her first big dress rehearsal
that'll be two weeks from Thursday
you